FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
welcome everyone.
We were super thrilled
to have Ezra Klein here.
As you all know, he's the
Editor-in-Chief of Vox.com,
and he's here in a conversation
with Richard Gingras, who
is our Senior Director of
Google News and Social Products.
And our team is
really, really excited
to see that you guys are so
interested in the intersection
of technology and media.
And I just know we're going to
learn a ton from today's talk
with Ezra.
His Vox and numerous other
web-only media organizations
are really disrupting the
industry and building something
really special
from the ground up.
And so if you guys
have questions,
we have a Dory, go/ezraklein.
You have your own go link.
It's easier to
isolate the questions.
EZRA KLEIN: I'm going to nod
like I know what that means.
Sounds great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
just a Democratic way
of asking questions
at the very end.
We'll also be
passing a microphone
if you guys want to ask
the questions live as well.
And with that,
Richard, take it away.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Great.
Thank you for being here.
We've got another good crowd.
We've been doing
a series of these,
and we'll continue to do so
with a large focus of sort
of looking behind the news.
And talking to
people, particularly
those who are really working
on the cutting edge of trying
to move every
dimension of journalism
forward into this exciting
and challenging new ecosystem
that we all consume
information through today.
So let's talk a
little bit about Ezra.
For those who aren't
aware of his background,
over the last decade, he has
actually a stellar and long
career, even though
you're 30 years old.
There's a kind of a multiple
in there with regard to me,
but we won't go there.
But over the last decade
you built a great reputation
as a political reporter,
columnist, blogger.
In 2009 Ezra joined "The
Washington Post," where
he managed the "wonk"
blog, being a policy
wonk as you are-- card carrying
policy wonk, I believe.
EZRA KLEIN: We do
give out cards, yeah.
RICHARD GINGRAS: It's
important we do so.
Which included the
work not only of Ezra,
but other political writers
at the "Post" as well,
and it very quickly became
the most popular blog
at "The Post."
In 2010, not long
thereafter, "The Week"
named him Blogger of the Year.
I've known Ezra for a bit.
He's attended at least one of
our Newsgeist unconferences,
and we've talked a lot
about the future of news
and how that ecosystem
needs to evolve.
And I think what was clear
is as Ezra's work evolved
over the last decade, I think
he became increasingly intrigued
with that notion of how should
approaches to journalism
and political coverage
change to meet the needs
and differences of the times.
He tried to do
that at "The Post,"
but I think had limited
ability to do that
within the confines of "The
Post," at least at that time.
We'll see how Jeff Bezos
evolves the culture
of that organization to
drive further innovation.
But given that he
really couldn't
have the kind of
license that he wanted
at "The Post," in
January last year
he joined Vox Media to
create and launch Vox.com.
Vox Media, as many of you
know, is the media company
that started SB Nation and The
Verge, headed by Jim Bankoff,
and they've been doing
interesting things.
His expressed
objective with Vox was
to, with Vox.com specifically--
Ezra's objective-- was
to focus more on providing
not just the day-to-day inside
the beltway back and forth
of the political sphere,
but really tried to get in
and provide more context, more
background, explainers
to give people a better
sense of the issues and how
they should look at them,
think about them.
So Ezra, welcome to Google.
EZRA KLEIN: Thank you.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Thank
you for being here.
As you know, I've been a very
strong and vocal proponent
in the industry regarding both
the need and the opportunity
to rethink the models
from the ground, up.
Not because everything's broken,
but simply because everything
is different.
Some of the things are broken,
but everything is, indeed,
different from how
people consume media,
how they interact with media,
how they interact with sources
of media, the tools you have,
the different workflows.
The very nature that the
definition of a news product
can be dramatically
different from what
we've seen in the past.
And I know that's been very much
part of your thinking with Vox.
So why don't we just start
off with the big question
of what's your vision
with Vox, and then
we can kind of probe
further into the details.
EZRA KLEIN: Sure.
So thank you, guys,
for having me.
It's exciting to be here.
I'm excited to see
somebody with a Vox shirt.
I'm excited to see a
menorah on the window.
Things are going well for me.
So as Richard said, I
covered policy and politics
at "The Post" for five years.
Before that, I was at
"The American Prospect."
And the focus of my work
has always been policy,
particularly health care
policy, economic policy
from roughly 2008 to 2012, the
complete and utter collapse
of the global financial system.
It's been a good ride of things
going terribly for the world.
And that has been, on the
one hand a lot of fun,
because I came into all
this through a back door.
I didn't want to
be a journalist.
I had never thought
about being a journalist.
I started a blog
and things kind of
took on some momentum from
there when I was in college.
But what I learned in
blogging was that actually you
had this incredible ability
to develop audiences and dig
into topics that
simply didn't work that
well in traditional
news formats.
When you're covering
something like Obamacare,
the sort of really thorny,
big, complex systems.
Writing about it once
isn't good enough.
I came up through magazines.
I went to "The
American Prospect."
And I interned at "The
Washington Monthly."
I remember we'd always be
in these editorial meetings,
and you would always have
to convince the editor
that whatever you were
going to say was new.
And so we'd say,
well, I got this idea.
I think it's a good idea.
And everybody would agree.
And then they'd be like,
yeah, but "The New Republic"
did that in June of 2004.
And it's like, so?
Nobody read "The New
Republic" doing that in 2004,
and if they did, they
don't remember it.
I've probably written 7,000
articles on Obamacare.
And what frustrated me
about that experience
was that I was
building something
that I thought had value
to the reader, which
was a body of knowledge
about Obamacare.
I actually have
read the dam Bill.
And I don't recommend
it, by the way.
If you want to do
something, I recommended
doing something other than
reading the Obamacare bill.
But I would get every
day these emails
from readers who, what
they needed to know
were the basics of
what was going on,
what were the exchanges,
how did the subsidies work,
how did the mandate work.
But the news does
not prize the basics.
The basics get locked in
actually pretty early.
The news prize are parts of
it that will change, And then
the parts of it that are
in conflict every day.
And so those are the parts
within the news pegs,
the things that your
editors actually
want from you, the
things that feel new.
You can actually say, well,
look, a politician said x.
I'm writing a thing about x.
They're not the thing that
the reader needs the most.
So one thing I recognized
while doing this coverage
was that as much as myself,
and then later Sarah Cliffe,
who's by far I think
the best health care
reporter in the
country, were really
I think doing a pretty good
job covering Obamacare,
certainly trying to.
We were not building the
thing our readers needed.
We were building an incredibly
fractured knowledge base
that you couldn't
get to unless you
had just incredible Google-fu.
This is what got me thinking a
lot about whether we were doing
the news right in
the digital age.
And the more I
gave this thought,
I sort of came to think there
were three, and arguably four,
but for me, three
relevant differences
between doing print
journalism, which
structured even digital
journals to a greater degree
than I think people
realize, and doing
purely digital journalism.
The first difference is speed.
And we as an industry
figured out how to do that.
We probably figured
that one out too well.
I think if anything, we're
a little bit too fast.
But we figured out that you
could be much faster online
than you ever could be in print.
So speed, you can put
the check in that box.
The second was length, and
I'd give us a C- on length.
An economist will
always tell you
in any industry,
what you want to look
for is the relevant scarcity.
You want to look for the
thing people don't have enough
of because that is going
to drive what they do.
In journalism, the
fundamental scarcity
has always been the
number of pages.
You have 64 in a magazine, you
have whatever number you had,
given the advertising you
had in that day's newspaper.
And everything was shaped
by this incredibly ruthless
competition for column inches.
At "The Washington Post,"
at "The New York Times,"
you don't talk about how
many words with stories,
you literally talk
about it in inches.
This was very
confusing to me when
they would say, how
long is your story?
And I would say, 800 words.
And they would say,
how many inches?
And I would say,
it's the internet.
It doesn't have inches.
But that was the
right way to think.
You had to lay out a paper.
It is about inches.
So an enormous amount
of how we did our work
was about how do we give people
the absolute most information
in the least amount of space.
And we made, as an industry, an
enormous number of decisions,
and compromises, and concessions
to the tyranny of page length.
The way we write articles,
reverse pyramid style,
is a mixture of dealing with
the problems of the telegraph,
because if you
get cut off, well,
the parts that got cut off
can just be lopped off.
It doesn't matter.
And then secondarily,
it is about getting
the maximum amount
of information
into the minimum
amount of space.
You don't have that
problem on the internet.
Do any of y'all read ClickHole?
Good.
It's a future of news.
ClickHole had a piece
recently that said--
I'm going to maybe mangle
the headline a bit,
but I went on this whaling
trip and it completely
changed my life.
And you clicked it, and it was
the entire text of "Moby Dick."
[LAUGHTER]
Which was a great joke,
because you all laughed.
But it's also a profound
thing to think about.
They put up the entire
text of "Moby Dick," which
is even longer than Obamacare
I think on a per word level--
although I haven't checked that.
And then they just published
a bunch of other articles.
A world in which you can put up
the entire text of "Moby Dick"
and then anything else you want
is a really different world.
It is a really different world.
And in journals I think
we're only just beginning
to figure out what being
unleashed from length means.
I think we are very,
very young at that.
I mean even in my experience
at all kinds of magazines
and newspapers,
you'll have people
do these incredible
pieces that we
get sent all over
the world to do.
And the piece really
should be 10,000 words.
But it'll get locked down to
1,600 or 2,300 for the magazine
or for the paper.
And then we won't-- not
because we think it's better,
just because that's
what we need to do--
then we won't put the
real version online.
We somehow bring the
constraint of print online.
So there are times when we're
getting past that now and times
when we aren't.
So I'd give us a
partial pass on that.
The third thing, and
the thing I think
people don't think enough
about, is persistence.
The web is persistent
in a way print is not.
If you don't ever throw out
your newspapers and magazines,
they will eventually grow mold
and you will inhale it and die.
It is very important to
throw out print news.
That is a really
profound way of thinking,
that the articles you do
every day or every week
or every month are
going to be trash.
They're going to be
a first approximation
inaccessible to readership.
Fundamentally, the publishing
tools built for the web,
and the way we do
news on the web
actually apes that, even though
it really doesn't need to.
We structure our home
pages by the newest stuff,
the stuff that is
happening right now.
The other stuff goes
into the archives.
It's not very findable.
You can go click and search.
I mean there are
things you can do.
And everyone has a search
product for their own website
that is just wildly
inferior to Google's.
So there are things you
guys do particularly.
But in general, those archives
become radically less valuable
with every passing day.
The thing that I
am obsessed with,
and the thing that
Vox is obsessed with
is persistence,
because that, to me,
is the answer for the
problem I had with Obamacare.
Persistence allows me to write
7,000 Obamacare articles.
Filter the relevant and
changing information.
Pull the body of knowledge
in those articles
out into something coherent,
continuously update it.
And instead of
constantly creating
new things where we redo the
work, simply update the thing
we have.
And instead of redoing 90% of
the work or 95% of the work,
change 5% of the work.
And I can give you guys
a slew of examples,
ranging from with have
these card stacks which
are kind of the body
of knowledge solution.
Not that we have figured that
out, but we are working on it.
And that is where we sort
of take ongoing new stories
and build out a sort of modular,
continuously updated topic
resource on them that we can
always attach to articles.
So that anybody coming
into the news midstream,
you're coming into
Obamacare nine months
after the discussion
has started.
You're looking into what's
going on in Syria years
after the Civil War has begun.
We have the thing
where we can say,
here's where you get caught up.
Here's where we
can give you what
you need to know to understand
all the other news stories
we're writing.
But in other ways, too.
We did a feature.
We sent Sarah Cliffe to Vermont
to report on their effort
to do single payer.
She did an incredible
feature from Vermont.
Six months later, Vermont's
single payer collapsed,
their effort collapsed.
So she did another feature.
What that feature did was
it was 40% or 50% new work,
and then 50% the contextual
parts of her original piece
that were still relevant.
That gave us the ability
to be much more efficient.
What single payer is.
What Vermont had been trying
to do had not changed.
All that work was relevant.
A lot of it is just getting
past the discomfort we feel.
A discomfort that I think is
born of the lessons and habits
we learned from print with
simply reusing our work
efficiently.
So for me, what we
need to figure out
is really speed, which I
think we're pretty far on.
Length, which I think we've done
some work on this in industry,
but are not there.
And persistence, which I
think we are nowhere on.
And if you were building
a news organization,
if the news was invented today
as opposed to in the past,
I think the way those
three things interacted
with it would just be
tremendously different.
And it's going to
take us a while
to figure out how to do that.
But for me, what Vox is about,
what measures our success to
me is not just unique visitors
a month, or page views,
or any of these sort
of other raw metrics.
In the long run,
it's whether or not
we are actually building a sort
of truly digital, genuinely
more efficient
newsroom that allows
us to serve our readers
better and do better work more
efficiently.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
let's talk a little bit
further about persistence,
because as you point out,
I think it's an absolutely
crucial dimension to how
journalists think
about the future.
And to your point
about inches, it's
always-- because in the prior
era it was edition-oriented
and yesterday's stuff went away.
Yesterday's stuff went into the
archive, went into the morgue.
I mean that's what
they called it.
Where content went to die.
And obviously, in
this realm it doesn't.
Persistence is a key attribute
of the web in general.
Wikipedia proves that every day.
Persistent links have value.
Build value over time.
You have approached this
with the card stacks.
So talk a little bit more
about the card stacks.
How they working?
How are users
responding to them?
What do you think
is good about them?
Where would you
like to take them?
EZRA KLEIN: Sure.
Am I allowed to curse at Google?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Oh, gosh yeah.
EZRA KLEIN: Oh, good.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Gosh, darn it.
EZRA KLEIN: The card
stacks are fucking hard.
They are, by far, the
hardest thing we do.
So for those of you who don't
have Vox shirts, the card
stacks are we built this
metaphor around the index cards
that some of us
used in high school.
Sort of the initial
idea of Vox was
could we create this giant--
these topic guides continuously
updated that would appear
under every article.
Somebody correctly noted
that would be very long.
So the brilliant
UX designers at Vox
came up with this cards
concept where-- so Obamacare,
for instance, is a card stack.
I think it's roughly 30 cards.
The first one would
be what is Obamacare?
Another one will be what is
a health insurance exchange?
Another one will be how to
see individual mandate work?
Another one will be
is Obamacare popular?
A third will be-- we're
not at third of that point.
Anyway, point is, that
they are very detailed.
The idea is that we do
our daily news reporting
and we filter that
reporting into them.
The cards themselves
can be pulled apart.
We can attach any
individual one to a story.
They take a tremendous amount
of work to do at the front end.
If we'd been doing this for
years it would be easier.
It would be more of a flywheel,
to use the metaphor that
seems so dominant out here.
But to just start one
up from the beginning
is just a lot of work.
We have roughly 120
of them now, roughly.
We have learned
a lot of lessons.
I'll walk through some of them.
We are actually doing
a big editorial sort
of V2 on card stacks right
now that we're rolling out
internally in the
next week or so.
And we're in the midst
of a huge product
redesign on card stacks.
I mean card stacks are something
we really hacked together.
And so I think they're
going to improve rapidly.
But we've been learning a lot.
We had didn't know how to
do this before we did it.
And one of the reasons
it's been so hard
is that there aren't actually
examples for us to follow.
Everything else, there's
so much great work
being done on the
web by so many people
that you can do really rapid
best practices discovery.
On card stacks, not at all.
So the initial
theory of card stacks
conceived of them as
a reference material.
I think we really
thought of them
in terms of the article format.
So you would have an
article, and articles
almost by necessity have
a lot of jargon in them.
I'm going to keep using
Obamacare here as an example
here, if people don't mind.
You have to talk about
insurance exchanges,
the individual mandate,
subsidies, the medical loss
ratio.
These are things that you
actually don't-- there is not
a more precise term
out there for them.
Those are just the terms.
So what we imagined
was these cards
that would actually have
really detailed explanations
of the core concepts
in a news story.
So we designed a discovery
mechanism for them
that was really
based on the article.
So you have this
yellow highlighting
in articles that
signifies a card is here.
We can attach the
card into the article.
And we write them,
and initially we
wrote them as
reference materials.
So we kind of thought about
what is each piece of the story
that we might need to
refer back to a lot.
As we watched the user
behavior on the cards,
that is not how people use them.
They did go from the
articles occassionally--
I mean it's not that
it didn't happen.
But the really big
wins in card stacks,
and what we really
found that surprised us,
when people went into a card,
they read about eight cards.
That is a tremendous
number on the internet.
Our bounce rate was in
the single digits, which
for every news story
I've ever seen,
it's usually
between 70% to 100%.
So people were going in and
they were going in deep.
And the way people were
finding them primarily,
for the ones that
really worked, was
that they were
searching them out.
It was not somebody coming and
reading an article and saying,
oh, I don't
understand that word.
It was somebody
coming and saying,
I don't understand Obamacare.
I don't understand the
Israel-Palestine conflict.
I don't understand bitcoin.
The answer is nobody
understands bitcoin.
So this forced a real overhaul.
We had not even designed
discovery mechanisms
that were consonant to that.
There is actually not a
home for the card stacks.
We build a home for
the cards stacks,
we build a search
for the card stacks.
But the real challenge was
how we were writing them.
We were writing them as
reference materials that
were meant to be, in many ways,
broken up and disaggregated.
We've moved much more
towards writing them
as full topic guides
that are meant
to be consumed by
somebody really
sort of trying to dig deep.
So we're doing a lot
of editorial revision
on what are the best
ways to do a card stack
and how to think about
the writing of it.
But it is much more-- we
almost look at it much more
like writing a feature
now than we think of it
like writing Wikipedia
or an encyclopedia entry.
And there's going to be a lot
of product changes in the coming
months that will be aligned to
that, which, unfortunately, I
can't talk about yet.
But we are sort of
overall, I would
say that we've actually
moved very dramatically.
Now, you also asked how
are they performing.
The answer is there's
incredible variability
in how are they performing.
A lot of it has to
do with you people.
They perform really
well when they're
at the top of the
Google results.
So we had a card stack
on ISIS, which is just
an exceptional piece of work by
a writer named Zack Beauchamp.
And that card stack on
ISIS was very, very early
in the conflict with ISIS
very early and their rise.
The structure is one of
our sort of normal ones
which we call Xfacts.
I think it's at this point,
17 facts about ISIS and Iraq
you should know.
Each card, it begins with ISIS
used to be al-Qaeda in Iraq.
Each card is sort of organized
around some crucial idea
in the conflict.
That card stack generated
a tremendous amount
of inbound linking, which led
to a sharp rise in the Google
rankings.
It's been read--
I can't remember
if this is the page number
or the reader number.
But it's been somethinged more
than 12 million or 15 million
times at this point.
So that's a huge success.
That's one of our biggest.
And we've had others
that are like that.
That's our highest
ranked one, but we've
had others that have
been huge successes.
Then we've had a number that
have just done nothing at all.
So one thing we're
trying to figure out
is how to deal a little bit
with the variability better.
One thing we're trying
to understand better
is the beautiful
mysteries of Google.
But in general, what we are
trying to figure out how to do
is, because we, to be honest,
don't know it ourselves,
is how do we tell people
about these things?
How do we let them
know this is there
for them when they need it?
Because the people
who most need the card
stack are the people who
don't know to look for it.
And so the thing that
we are struggling with,
I think have some cool
ideas on, but the thing
we are dealing with and
trying to figure out
is really about
the distribution.
Like I'm pretty
confident at this point,
particularly in the newer
versions of the product.
We just released one on
the European debt crisis,
which I think is
just exceptional,
by Matthew Yglesias.
But I don't know yet.
I have theories,
but I don't know yet
how to match the
card stack itself
with the people who need it.
Because the people coming to Vox
to read about the European debt
crisis, well, they
might, in fact,
be interested in
reading the card stack.
They're actually
almost the opposite
of the intended audience.
And so trying to figure out
that match up better is,
I think, our big challenge here.
When they work it is just the
most beautiful thing to me.
It's the thing I'm
happiest about at Vox.
But I want to get the number
of them working up higher.
So I'd say they've
been successful.
We've gotten good
traffic off of them.
I'd say that we've
learned a ton, which
is the point of the
first eight months of it.
But we have a long way to go to
build the accessible resource
that we want people to have.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Great.
We want to open this up a bit.
As I mentioned, we've got people
who have been putting questions
into the Dory today.
The one that's been
voted to the top
is going to play right
to the deepest, deepest
heart of your
policy walk nature--
EZRA KLEIN: All right.
RICHARD GINGRAS: --with
a massively open question
that I'll be very interesting
to see what your answer is.
"If you could pass one
constitutional amendment, what
would it be?"
EZRA KLEIN:
Constitutional amendments.
That's good, because
they're scary things,
constitutional amendments.
RICHARD GINGRAS: This
is like stump the chump.
EZRA KLEIN: No, I like it.
All right.
So my biggest concern
in American politics
is the interaction
between party polarization
and a disaggregated checks
and balance-oriented system.
So when I think
about what you need
to change in American
politics, basically my argument
is party polarization is
not a transient phenomenon.
It is the equilibrium of
a multiparty democracy.
And what is seen as
the sort of golden age
of American politics,
sort of mid-20th century
period in which the parties were
non-polarized, where you could
have a hardcore
conservative like Strom
Thurmond, the Democratic
Party, and a hardcore liberal
like, hey, George Romney
in the Republican Party,
that is the aberration.
That is the thing that
didn't make sense.
The problem is we have
a political system that
does not work with polarization.
The aberration was about race.
When race receded from the
front of American politics,
the aberration began
to resolve itself.
And now we are in
a position where
we have essentially
parliamentary style
parties without
parliamentary style rules.
So if I were going to start
amending the Constitution,
and I want to be very clear
that if left to my own devices,
I would not.
Because I think
constitutional amendments
are very tough things.
But within the context
of the question,
I would be looking
to move America
closer to a parliamentary
style political system,
where in the president
and the majority
and Congress are
matched in a clearer way
than is currently the case.
It is a troubling fact, if
think about it long enough,
that America is the only
constitutional presidential
democracy of its kind to last
for an extremely long time.
Virtually every other
system constructed like ours
has collapsed for a
very simple reason.
That there is no
constitutional way
to resolve disputes between
the executive, which
has democratic legitimacy,
and the legislature, which
also has democratic legitimacy.
So when you get into something
like congressional Republic
and say they won't
raise the debt ceiling,
and Barack Obama says you
gotta raise the debt ceiling,
we don't actually have an
answer to that, except for well,
we better come up with one.
Now, maybe we always will,
but I'm not confident in that.
So I would be looking to move
us toward something where there
are clearer lines
of accountability
and less possibility of
catastrophic breakdown.
It's, by the way, a
very notable thing
that we have helped a
number of other countries
develop their political system.
You think of the countries we
occupied after World War II,
like Japan, we have not
pushed them towards ours.
And the reason is is
actually pretty well known
in the literature that this
kind of system is unstable.
It's worked in America
because we've had-- one,
we're just fucking awesome.
But two, we've
had, traditionally,
very diffuse parties.
It's really unusual.
But I think the specific unique
qualities of our democracy
and our party system that
have allowed it to work
are slowly vanishing,
and I think
it's putting us in a
position that lends itself
to very dangerous crises.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Great answer.
Let's turn to the
people in the room.
Question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in talking
about card stacks,
you make a distinction between
Wikipedia style and featured.
Can you elaborate on that?
EZRA KLEIN: Of course.
So for those-- I'm not
sure that we heard.
So he was saying that I make
a distinction between writing
these card stacks the way
you'd write a Wikipedia article
and saying that we think
of them a little bit more
like a feature article.
In journalism, features
have a kind of fuzzy meaning
that makes sense
internally, and I'll
try to make it make
sense externally.
But it's a meaning
that has come to be
used in the word long form.
Feature stories
are lengthy, deep,
detailed, heavily reported,
although not always,
pieces that are meant to be
read through from the beginning
to the end.
Whereas in Wikipedia, one
of its great strengths is it
is a reference material
that is not actually
meant to be read through
beginning to end.
It is episodic.
It is, in many ways, modular.
I don't know how you
all use Wikipedia,
but I go and I go
to the little box
and I click on the
part of the box I need
and then I go down to that
anchor tag in the story.
So as opposed to trying
to write these stacks
in this kind of context,
where what we are doing
is fundamentally
defining the terms
and giving relevant
information about the topic.
We are moving it more
towards a style, which
we think a lot
about when we think
about the word "explaining,"
which has influences coverage
much beyond card stacks.
We are trying to give
people a sense of the bigger
picture and the context.
We talk a lot internally
about the difference
between offering a definition
and offering an explanation.
And I think that too much of
our early work, our early card
stacks, pushed
towards definitions.
This is what
insurance exchange is
in words that are not
insurance exchange.
As opposed to trying to
explain, like listen,
we've been working
with this topic a lot.
We've done a lot
of reporting on it.
of research on it.
We've done a lot
of thinking on it.
This is what we think is kind
of the bigger picture here.
This is what we think you
need to understand it.
And I'll give a
specific example on this
because I know that's
a little fuzzy.
The European debt crisis.
One way to approach
the first card in that
is to say what is the
European debt crisis,
or what is the
European currency zone,
or whatever you
might want to do.
And to sort of very tightly
try to answer that question.
The European debt
crisis is a situation
in which a number of
European countries
have seen their risk level
rise up in the markets,
and as such, they're
unable to issue new debt.
They are trying to get it from
the European Central Bank,
but the European
Central Bank does not
want to print money for them.
You can describe the economics.
The way we did it is-- Matthew
Yglesias has covered this
a lot, says basically,
the fundamental thing
you need to understand
is that the Eurozone
is a political union that
is also a currency union.
The reason they are doing all of
these things, all these things
that do not make economic
sense and are leading
to persistent economic
crisis is that achieving
the political objective
of furthering integration
between the various
countries of Europe
has trumped the economic
objectives of the Eurozone,
at least temporarily.
And so trying, in that way,
to not just sort of say here
is everything you
kind of need to know
to understand the words
used in an article about it.
But to try to say, as you
would in a feature piece,
where you'd gone and reported
in Europe for a month
to really try and say,
here's what we think
is really going on.
Here's what you need to know,
not just to follow along,
but to understand it.
But that's fuzzy.
I would like to be able to
draw that line more precisely
than I'm able to.
AUDIENCE: It sounded like
you were saying that,
if I understood you
correctly, that your audience
for the cards is different from
your audience for the news?
Is that correct?
EZRA KLEIN: No, there's overlap.
There is some difference.
So cards are likely to be found,
for instance, by Google search,
which is not untrue
for news articles.
But a lot more of our, say,
daily news audiences were
current people who like coming
to the Vox.com home page,
or follow us on Twitter,
or follow us on Facebook.
Whereas a greater percentage
of the card audience
is people searching for a
specific topic knowledge, who
never intended to come
specifically to Vox.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is, are you doing anything
to try to bring those audiences
more together, so to pull one
over to the other side,
pull the card audiences
more into your news
side, and the news
side more into the card?
And then related to that, a
lot of what you've been saying
goes against a lot of
the assumptions in news
organizations that people
who are reading things online
have a very short
attention span,
so everything needs
to be very short.
But you have a very
different take on that.
So if you could answer
both those questions,
I think they're reall--
EZRA KLEIN: Definitely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EZRA KLEIN: So in
terms of trying
to convert the card stack
audience to a daily Vox
audience, there are different
things you can do there.
We have some level of
links into the content.
We have, at the
end of the cards,
you can explore other cards.
I think our idea is that we
want to build something that
is more like an
internet utility.
And that the best way
to build the audience
for the cards, which is
fundamentally the aim there,
is to just make that
experience as good as we can.
Without saying too
much about our plans,
I would say we're actually
moving further away
from trying to push people in
the cards to other Vox content,
and moving more towards
us making the cards,
the experience we think they
should be, and as useful
an experience as they can be.
Ultimately, I think
the best thing for Vox
is that people across the
vast acreage of the internet
come to rely on and find
useful the card stacks,
and I think that
the rest of the site
will benefit
dramatically from that.
But I'm not trying
to use one as sort
of a selling point
for the other.
To your other
question about length.
In some ways I think I'd
give other news organizations
a little bit more credit.
I think that something we've
all discovered in recent years
is that long form works
really well on the web.
That people's
attention spans are
way beyond what we
give them credit for.
Now, a lot of short stuff
works really well, too,
and Vox has a
combination of both.
We do all kinds of stuff.
But it just is not my experience
that readers punish you
for going into detail.
The majority of the stuff
we do that does best
is actually pretty
detailed, pretty long.
And the truth is, if you even
think about other organizations
and outlets, it's often true.
To use a player who a lot
of people would imagine
is like the apotheosis of
short on the internet, which
is BuzzFeed.
If you really look
at what they do,
for instance, they are
very intent on signaling
how long things are going to be.
They do not have
lists of seven things,
or three things, or nine things.
It's 42 things only children
from 1993 will understand.
It's about showing
that there's going
to be a level of
comprehensiveness and length
in here.
In general, I think the
internet rewards work.
I think that it rewards stuff
that people find valuable.
A lot of the short stuff that
works well on the internet
tends to not actually be short.
What it tends to be is an
embed of something long.
So people, I think, will
often say like a John Oliver
video does really well across
a number of news sites.
That's short.
But actually, it's a 17-minute
video about state legislatures
and why they're corrupt.
So to the reader it's very long.
So to some degree I
think we underestimate
the internet audience
a lot on this stuff.
I think there is a really
significant audience
of people who want good content.
The big polarization, I think,
in terms of online news is
between people who want
it and people who don't.
But once you're
bought in, once you're
one of the people who've decided
as a hobby in your life you're
going to read the news, you tend
to be into a lot of good stuff.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
I think the term--
I'm going to go to
the crowd in the cloud
again for a second here.
I think the term utility--
EZRA KLEIN: It's
weird interacting
with all these real
people at Google.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I know.
It's true.
They're actually projections.
I think the word
utility's a good one.
A phrase that I've often
used is knowledge utility.
And we had a panel
here recently,
part of the same series,
with investigative journalist
from ProPublica Center of
Investigative Journalism.
ProPublica has been
creating knowledge utilities
off of data.
How can I find a
dialysis treatment center
and understand whether
they're better or worse
than the one two miles away.
EZRA KLEIN: They do
incredible jobs with that.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Great work.
EZRA KLEIN: Great work.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Their
newsrooms right now
are in the area of
20% data journalists.
So I'm curious at Vox, what's
your view on data journalism?
How much of it is a part
of what you're doing?
What you want to do?
EZRA KLEIN: We have some
exciting data journalist
announcements coming.
OK, I have complicated
ideas on this.
So enjoy your long answer.
Also, was that a cloud question
or was that your question?
RICHARD GINGRAS: That
was a cloud question.
EZRA KLEIN: OK.
You spoke it so eloquently.
OK, data journalism.
We have often been grouped
as a data journalist outlet
with a bunch of others like
FiveThirtyEight and The Upshot,
and other things like
that that started roughly
around the time we did.
I have not thought of us
as a data journalism shop
just because we have not really
built out that capacity yet.
Now, our journals have
to be data literate.
We have a very high
premium on knowing
how to do the basic work of
working with spreadsheets,
of working with graphs,
charts, tables, maps.
We have a lot of people
who can do regressions.
It's not like some mysterious
other language in the newsroom.
So I've tried very hard
to integrate those skills.
But we've not built too
big of a separate team,
although we're going to be
making some hires pretty
shortly in that area, or
announcing some hires pretty
shortly in that area.
But let me talk for minute
just about what I think it is,
because this is where
we're going with it,
and it's one reason it's taken
us some time to get there.
I think that data journalism
has frequently been conflated,
not by ProPublica, but by the
sort of media conversation
with the data visualization.
You put up a graph and
people are like ah-ha!
Data journalism.
No.
That's a graph.
It's a chart.
That's why I put in
one chart as opposed
to in one piece of data
journalism in the headline.
There is a lot of performance
of data on the internet
right now, much of which I have
been a big part in pushing.
It's great.
I hope you all share
it on Facebook.
But that is not data journalism.
To me, what is interesting
about data journalism,
to me, what makes data
journalism journalism is what
you are doing is you
are figuring out ways
to create data information
sources that you are then
using to find and
report stories.
So to talk about Nate Silver
for a minute, what was amazing
about Nate's work on
the election is that--
and I think it was
often misunderstood,
because people get
very, oh, my god, math.
Nate had created a model that
was feeding a spreadsheet.
And every day that
spreadsheet was giving Nate
a story about the election.
Nate was the chief correspondent
of Nate Silver spreadsheet.
That was an amazing
thing to be because he
had a monopoly
over those stories.
And the stories are better
than most of the other stories
people were writing.
So to me, that was
data journalism.
Nate had found a way
to pull data sources
into a comprehensible usable
format that could then
inform a stream of
ongoing stories.
Data journalism to me is
doing journalism off of data.
And so when I think about
how we're going to do it,
and when I think about
how it needs to be done,
I think that there's been
too much and too much
talking about pretty
interactives and graphics,
and too little about the actual
data side of journalism, which
is what information sources
are you going to use.
How are you going to make
them into something that's
telling you true
facts about the world,
or at least leading
you towards ways
of finding true facts
about the world.
And how you make
that information
accessible to your
journals, and then how will
you make it accessible and
transparent to your readers.
So we're going to be
pushing into that.
I think we have some
cool ideas there.
But I think that
for me, we've had
a lot of data
visualization at Vox.
We're reasonably good at that.
But data journalism is
a much harder thing--
ProPublica is really
one of leaders in it.
And it is--
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Making money from it.
EZRA KLEIN: Yes.
I can't speak to their--
RICHARD GINGRAS: They are.
EZRA KLEIN: So that's great.
I'm a big fan of journalism
that makes money.
So if it turns out
data journalism
is money journalism,
that's even better.
That's my favorite kind
of journalism data.
So to me, I don't think Vox
has pushed far on that yet.
We've done a lot of
data visualization,
but we are building
out the capacity
and building out a
number of things required
for us to do the sort
of separate thing
that I think of as
data journalism,
not just my reporter knows
how to use a spreadsheet.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I want
to shift, if we can,
to another dimension of
the architecture of news.
And this deals, to me, with
the facet of credibility.
I mean the internet is
an extraordinary thing.
It's broadened
expression tremendously.
Of course, there's more
wheat, there's more chaff.
It's a maelstrom of expression.
And anyone with a
thought can do so.
And as we know, it's also
great at amplifying untruths,
as well as it is truths.
Unfortunately, in this era, it
becomes increasingly hard right
now to differentiate between
the good and the bad.
We've started a project--
we-- Sally Lehrman
is here who's also an
esteemed journalist
and a Fellow at the
Markkula Center for Ethics.
And we've started an initiative
within the industry called
The Trust Project, which really
pokes at the notion of how
can we, in the industry,
evolve the model of journalism
such that more
dimensions that support
the credibility of
the work are there.
And the interesting thing
is that quality news
organizations, and
I put yours in that,
are doing the necessary
things to support this.
You have expertise.
You do deep work that
supports your conclusions.
You have editorial
workflows where
people double check your
work and sign off on it.
Yet most of this is not
exposed to the audience at all.
I don't know that Adam Ellick's
story at "The New York Times"
went through three weeks
of vetting with editors
and lawyers before he put it
up on the web where it was then
rewritten 500 times by others
who did not have expertise
and didn't do his work.
So I'd really love
to get your thoughts
as you think about Vox's
evolution of its models
as to what you think you
might do to really buttress
the notion that you do
have that credibility
and expertise to get
me to be comfortable
trusting what you say.
EZRA KLEIN: So this is
a really hard problem.
And it is a harder
problem now than it's even
been at any other time
when I've been doing this,
because so many people
who come to your site
are coming through social media.
You're getting so many people--
or even through search.
So you're getting
so many people just
like they have found
the link or the headline
and they're coming in
and they don't really
know what they're getting.
I remember back in the days
of yore when I started a blog,
and the way you
got traffic was you
got direct links
from other people.
And so you were
getting traffic based
on an implicit endorsement, or
at times, an anti-endorsement--
this guy's the stupidest
idiot on the face
of the earth--
from someone else.
And so the readership came
with some understanding
of what was going on.
If you guys have not read
Richard and his colleagues'
work on the idea of The
Trust Project on Medium,
it's worth doing.
It's very thought provoking.
And I know that's sort of
what we're talking about here.
So I've been thinking
about that a lot today,
and since you sent it to me.
And let me tell you what
worries me about all this stuff,
because I really do want
to find an answer to this
and I don't know how.
So we invest a lot
at Vox on things
that I think do increase
the quality of the product.
We have a lot of editors.
Everything gets edited.
Everything now over 800
words gets copy edited.
It gets a secondary copy
edit before it goes up.
When we do data visualization,
that has a separate look
and run through.
We have a very tight
corrections policy,
where we will correct-- in
some ways maybe too tight.
But we really try to be, like
if we get anything wrong.
Like I wrote 2005 rather than
'06-- that's a correction.
We put up a chart from the
US Department of Agriculture.
Their chart was wrong.
We got them to
correct their chart.
We corrected our story.
We're doing a lot that is
meant to really build up
transparency and credibility
with the audience.
Here's where I get
scared of what we know
and what we don't know about
how we'll end up interacting.
Two things.
One is formalism,
trust formalism.
So I think of
"Bloomberg News" here,
which I've done a
lot of work with.
I was a columnist
for "Bloomberg View."
Everything there.
You have the name
of the editor, you
have the name of
the copy editor.
Medium actually does a nice
job of this on their long form
stories-- who was the
illustrator, who was the--
and it's really
showing you there
were a lot of people who
worked on this piece.
On features we
actually do it too.
We show on features
who is the editor, who
is the designer, who
is the writer, who
is the-- all the
different players that
were involved to make the piece.
The only thing I
would say is that
in my experience of the internet
and of journalism in general,
that is actually
not what separates
good work and bad work.
It is not what
separates things I
think you should trust from
things I think you should not.
Editing is an incredibly
important thing.
It makes work so much better.
It really is critical.
And we are hiring
a lot of editors.
If any of you would like to
be our deputy culture editor,
let me know.
But a lot of the true lies
on the internet are edited.
And a lot of them
aren't even factually
wrong, they're just
completely incorrect.
And I think there are a lot of
ways to-- if we all just start
writing down our editors
and our copy editors
and creating a sort of map
of how much we did on it,
I worry that's going to get
gamed, because that's a model.
It's like a clear thing.
It's a clear-- and stuff
like that, it begins to work.
If Google began to put
it in the algorithm,
it will get gamed rapidly.
I've just seen this before.
So that worries me.
And then the other
thing that worries
me is somehow making
trust too much of a stand
in for resources.
A lot of the really
important thinking
and a lot of the really
true things on the internet
come from people outside
of the mainstream
for all kinds of, in some ways
obvious, reasons, I think.
I think back to
the Iraq War, when
Juan Cole, who is a Middle
Eastern history professor-- I
believe he was out at U
Michigan at that point--
was one of the
really best guides.
Not literally everything
he said was right,
but compared to what you were
getting out of the main papers,
this blogger, who was
just a history professor,
was way better, and he was
a way truer guide to it.
But he would have been destroyed
by something like this,
because he had no editors,
he had no copy editors.
He just had his own expertise.
So when I think about this,
I think of two things,
and they're fuzzy
and I don't like it,
because I want people to
know the work we're putting
into what we're
doing, and I just
have not figured
out a good solution.
But one, I do think of the
card stacks as being part of it
for us, because I think that
if you can show that you've
been really working
on this story a lot,
you've been diving deep into
it, you've been doing the job,
then at least you
can show your reader
why they should trust you.
You can show them you didn't
just come to this today
because you noticed
on CrowdTangle it
was popping on Facebook.
You've been covering, say, the
Bill Cosby sexual harassment
things for six months now.
You've written 200 stories.
You've done a full timeline.
You really know what's going on.
Another thing there, which
this one isn't as helpful,
but is really just--
and it's an old blogging
thing is showing your work,
is linking to your work.
I'll tell you a place where
I really worry about this.
We talked about the performance
of data a few minutes ago.
There is a bad habit journalists
have, and we've done it too--
I'm not exempting
us-- to treat whatever
is in an abstract
of a working paper
as a true fact about the world.
We use academic papers,
we use academic research
as some kind of synonym
for this is correct.
These people are
at a university,
so this is a true estimate
of the macroeconomic impact
of blah, blah, blah, blah.
Whereas, that's very rarely--
it's very rarely that simple.
So something that we're
thinking about a lot
on this particular piece
of it is how not just
to show the readers we're
being not just data informed,
but data skeptical.
But actually make
sure we have processes
that force our writers to know
what the actual data says too.
And I've thought a lot about
it, and we may actually
do something like this of
having annotations in which it's
boring to explain the
methodology of things
in a piece because you might
have to do it six times
and it's not that interesting.
But if you have a
strong annotation system
maybe you do want to do that.
Maybe particularly when you're
relying heavily on a study,
you do want to be saying here
is how the study was done.
Here's what the sample size was.
You don't need to roll over
that if you don't want it,
but it's there if you want it.
And then at least you
know and the reader
knows that the writer at least
knows how the study was done.
So I'm trying to think
about things like that
where we can somehow show not
that we had the resources to do
the work, or not even
what our process was,
but in a very specific way
on this particular article.
Like we went deeper even
than what you see here.
We made sure we understood
the underpinnings of it.
But I'll just be
flatly honest with you
because I don't want
to bullshit you.
I have not come to
anything on this
that I feel super good about.
I do not know how to
say to someone, how
to show someone clearly.
We have, for years
before this, been
talking to the relevant
experts in this space
and have come to the story
with a body of knowledge.
And when we tell
you what's going on,
even though our take maybe
was less interesting than some
of the hot takes by people who
have not been following this
in any clear way and
parachuted in today,
it's a more trustworthy one.
I've not figured
out how to do that.
I'm hoping you will
figure it out for me.
RICHARD GINGRAS: It's
a complex problem,
and I wouldn't pretend that
there are silver bullets,
and there's a lot
more to discuss there.
We're almost out of
time, but maybe we
have time for one more fast
question and a fast answer.
Anyone want to--
EZRA KLEIN: I make no promises.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
--volunteer with one?
Who's got a fast question?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any advice for Google?
What could we do to help users
benefit from good journalism
that we aren't doing?
EZRA KLEIN: Aside from lifting
Vox in the search rank,
and this is just a matter
of algorithmic precision.
I'll go back to persistence
here for a minute.
I think the thing that Google
should be thinking about,
Google News should
be thinking about,
maybe that Facebook
should be thinking about,
that others should be thinking
about is to what degree
the algorithms that
y'all use right now,
end up prizing iterative, brand
new reporting all the time.
To what degree recency is
a measure that is actually
forcing us to do things in
a way that is not the best
way for our readers,
or that we're
capable of in
digital journalism.
I'll use Facebook as the
example here because honestly,
I know a little bit less
about how your search works.
But you actually get downgraded
for putting the same URL
into Facebook repeatedly.
But if I want to do an explainer
on, say, something fast moving,
instead of rewriting
it all the time,
I want to keep updating that
and making that the very best it
can be.
And I can make that piece
into something much richer
than I could if I were
having to constantly split it
into new pieces.
But I'm going to get
penalized for doing that.
And so I think that something
that you guys should
be thinking about is how
much-- moving journalism
onto the internet does not
make it digital journalism.
Just the fact that it's
hosted on a web page
does not get you there.
And so a lot of us have built
our workflows, our processes,
all kinds of things, in
journalism and outside of it,
based upon what we intuitively
understand as journalism,
what our habits
are in journalism.
And there's a lot more pressure
keeping us in old workflows
than people realize.
The way the publishing
tools are made.
The way the social
algorithms work.
All kinds of things
push us to do things
kind of like they've
always been done,
just published on the internet.
So if I were you
guys, I'd be thinking
long-term about how to
make sure that-- I'm not
saying you should push away
from how things have been done,
but how to make sure that
you are not penalizing
non-traditional approaches
to telling these stories
and delivering this information.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Very good point,
and I think everyone here
would agree with that.
I want to thank you very much,
Ezra, for being here with us.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD GINGRAS: For
your thoughtfulness,
and most importantly, for
your efforts to continue
to move the ball forward, and
rethinking the future of news.
EZRA KLEIN: Well, thank
you all for coming out.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Thank you.